foreign
act this is the controversial measure
which eliminates cash bail Illinois will
be the first state in the nation to end
cash bail starting next year and that is
sparking a concern that more criminals
could be out on the street the
controversy still raging over Illinois's
new safety act the safety act was voted
on in the middle of the night it was
passed through the middle of the night
last year then signed by governor
pritzker
you know what I said that this is the
most dangerous law I've ever seen I I
believe that I believe this is very
dangerous I don't think we know what's
coming from this I think we can project
that if criminals are allowed to run
free and police officers can't protect
citizens citizens are going to start
protecting themselves criminals running
around
your own cash Bond I just don't like
they don't have anything to lose
nothing to lose well I think sometimes I
keep the the
wrong ones you know we're in jail and
the right one's out of jail I think it's
stupid I think
I've worked for the system for 28 years
and
I think it's about the dumbest thing
Illinois has come up with so far
the safety act that we're discussing was
a a law that was passed in January of
20.
uh of January of 2021 and it goes into
effect January of 2023. it talks about
Criminal Justice Reform that talks about
police reforms it talks about bail
reforms that talk about the judicial
review it talks about
um elections so it has all these
different things and I think that's one
of it's been challenged several times I
think over a dozen times already it's
being challenged in court the whole
thing is concerning to me because it was
just a potpourri of everything and it
didn't bring law enforcement judges it
didn't bring the all the stakeholders in
place but I think the things that stand
out as being that you know most
egregious and most dangerous right out
of the gate are the no cash bail they've
essentially said that judges have two
options they can either hold someone
indefinitely
or they cannot hold someone but they can
only hold people for like seven
different types of offenses so it's
murder and class sex felonies
essentially so things like second-degree
murder aggravated assault aggravated
battery arson uh threatening a public
official aggravated dischargeable weapon
those are things that are not
um that are not part of those categories
so they cannot be held unless a judge
finds a specific um that they're a wolf
but they're a Flight Risk but you can't
use any past history of not showing up
as so how can you possibly prove that
there are future Flight Risk or they're
a threat to a specific person so threat
to threat to the public is not an issue
so if someone's on a robbery spree it is
random they're not a threat to a
specific person they're allowed to walk
free
um the the other thing that is it's it's
talked about but is buried in here is
that trespassing was lowered to a Class
B misdemeanor from a Class A misdemeanor
and Class B and C misdemeanors were
Rewritten to say that
um officers shall issue a citation which
in legal terms shallot is a really
important word it means that they must
issue a citation means they can't put a
hand on somebody so in other words they
can't remove a trespasser from someone's
property so now they get to stay on that
property in that business on your on
your property at your house Etc you know
when I said that this is the most
dangerous law I've ever seen I I believe
that I believe this is very dangerous I
don't think we know what's coming from
this I think we can project that if
criminals are allowed to run free and
police officers can't protect citizens
citizens are going to start protecting
themselves
and take the law into their own hands
and in many cases you know citizens are
going to go too far in taking the longer
their own hands so I think any time we
do that we create we have the potential
to create Anarchy because we don't have
because law enforcement can't do their
job and then people feel that they have
to do that job and people aren't trained
in the use of force they're not trained
to de-escalate situation they're not
trained to do these things so you know
lots of bad things can happen out of
this and it's and it puts potentially
spiral out of control relatively quickly
I I don't know what they I mean I think
if you look at it what they hoped it
would do is basically uh it was
basically to allow criminals to go free
I mean it's just the whole Criminal
Justice Reform the criminal shouldn't be
held and I think that's absurd and it
basically prioritizes criminals Over law
abiding citizens and police that's not
to say that there aren't needed reforms
um but the answer is not to just
basically get rid of our criminal
justice system and allow criminals to
run free that is not the answer we have
to keep violent criminals behind bars I
really hope that this thing gets uh gets
repealed I hope the voters wake up and
and uh you know do the right thing I
mean their votes matter they really do
matter and you can really make a
difference in this particular uh bill by
voting and like I said by voting the
people out who voted for it and by
voting out the governor that signed it
and that's how it gets changed